Critics spend their lives telling you which
movies are good and which movies are not so
good.
But just because a movie's been savaged by
critical reception, that doesn't actually
mean it's not worth your time.
Here are some surprisingly great, but critically
hated, movies you can watch on Netflix right
now.
National Treasure
"I'm gonna steal it."
"What?"
"I'm going to steal the declaration of independence."
National Treasure feels like someone threw
Indiana Jones in a blender with The Da Vinci
Code and then added some Nicolas Cage strangeness
on top.
Cage stars as the ridiculously-named Benjamin
Franklin Gates, a treasure hunter who has
to decode a series of historical clues that
will lead him to a long-buried treasure hidden
by the Freemasons.
Despite the high concept and a packed cast
of talented actors, the film only managed
a 44 percent critic rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
Despite that, National Treasure is a hoot,
with laugh-out loud dialogue and some surprisingly
accurate historical facts.
Well, besides all that stuff about hidden
Freemason treasure, that is.
"On the back of a hundred-dollar bill is an
etching of Independence Hall based on a painting
done in the 1780s who, and the artist was
actually a friend of Benjamin Franklin's!
It's wonderful."
Mascots
Christopher Guest has been a part of some
of the best comedy films of the last 40 years,
from Best in Show to This Is Spinal Tap, and
his faux-documentary comedic stylings are
still hilarious today.
"Why don't you just make 10 louder and make
10 be the top number and make that a little
louder?"
"These go to 11."
In short, the man is a comedy legend, so it's
no wonder that 2016's Mascots, his first feature-length
film in almost a decade, came with some high
expectations.
The film follows a group of sports mascots
who gather for the Fluffies, an annual competition
and awards ceremony for mascotry.
Unfortunately, the hype might have been too
much for the film, as indicated by its 50
percent Rotten Tomatoes rating.
While it might not have delighted critics,
or even most audiences, the film's absolutely
worth a watch.
It's packed to the brim with bizarre characters
played by some of the best comedic actors
in the business.
“Bronze Fluffy, Silver Fluffy, and Gold
Fluffy.
And believe me, every mascot knows just how
important those awards can be."
Wet Hot American Summer
Some films become so ingrained in popular
culture that it's hard to remember they weren't
box office smashes or critical darlings when
they came out.
Wet Hot American Summer is a perfect example.
The cast list alone should encourage you to
see it — it's led by a roster of comedy
all-stars that includes Paul Rudd, Ken Marino,
Amy Poehler, Bradley Cooper, Elizabeth Banks,
H. Jon Benjamin and many more.
"You taste like a burger.
I don't like you anymore."
Unfortunately, critics couldn't quite click
with the film, giving it a 33 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes.
Still, Wet Hot American Summer was ahead of
its time, and you should absolutely check
out this comedy classic.
"I'd like to take this opportunity to thank
you all for making the last eight weeks, without
rival, the best summer of my entire life."
Trailer Park Boys: The Movie
An adaptation of the long-running Canadian
comedy show of the same name, Trailer Park
Boys: The Movie follows three friends in a
trailer park as they try to get rich through
petty crime.
The joy of the show has always been about
watching the natural chemistry between the
characters, and the movie extends that simple
pleasure beautifully.
"Julien, pull over, man, I gotta p---."
"Ricky, we're being pursued by the cops, no,
not gonna happen."
"I can't hold it.
I can't.”
The movie is so great at creating a sense
of rhythm that you can't help but relax into
it, despite its negative critical reviews.
"What's your friend doing?"
“Bubbles, don’t you move.”
Goon: Last of the Enforcers
The original Goon was a surprisingly engaging
sports movie with a sweet romance and some
genuinely great acting from Seann William
Scott in the lead role.
Unfortunately, the sequel, Goon: Last of the
Enforcers, didn't fare quite as well critically,
only managing to muster 42 percent at Rotten
Tomatoes.
While it might not be as electrifying as the
first film, Last of the Enforcers is a capable
sequel, bringing back fan favorite characters
and featuring even more grotesque violence
on the ice.
Through it all, Scott anchors the film as
the lovable, thick-headed Doug Glatt with
the same easy charisma and puppy-like enthusiasm
that he showed the first time out.
"And that's when I got bit by the sellin’
insurance bug.
She laid eggs right inside of me and now you're
here."
"I'm allergic to eggs."
"You're an idiot.
Nobody's allergic to eggs."